[Music]
all right so today we're gonna be
watching uh a jubilee video this is a
jubilee video all right you guys seem to
like the jubilee video that we did last
week odd one out by jubilee
jubilee is doing an episode on codyco
fans i got so many tweets that were like
do you know about this you know about
this and all i got to say to that is
just
shut up
you'll see we brought together seven
cody co fans i'm a cody hill fan i'm a
cody co-fan i'm a cody coke fan i'm a
cody co-fan i'm a cody co-fan i am a
cody coke fan and i'm a kodiko fan
actually i am cody ko and i'm not a fan
one is actually the real cody co but
none of the fans know cody is in the
game if the group discovers who the liar
is they'll split a cash prize if cody
survives he wins the entire prize
with mics and cameras off can the fans
find who's the odd one out
alright my fake name is josh miller
what's my background i'm a rabid fan of
codyco
my strategy for the game is to be
friendly but also put pressure on people
i'm honestly looking out for a noel
miller fan a noel miller fan could
easily know enough general information i
am a kodiko fan but i don't know that
much about koriko i literally googled
cody koufax just to make sure that i
knew enough about him i love cody ko and
hopefully he sees this video i cannot
tell you how freaked out i was when i
found out that cody had reviewed my
video i'm gonna
judge a book by its cover right now this
is the girl that's not in it for love
i think i'm gonna win uh it's either
that or getting kicked out in the first
round i'm gonna be reciting
my his my favorite videos of his
all the best memes you're old dude
that's a good one i can't wait
let's go
oh
what do i say hey lol
i said hey
i don't know what to say ashley's
bitmojis that's as hell
i don't like joe something's off
okay what do we even ask what are we
even ask
where's everyone from i'm gonna say
where is everyone from that's fine right
that's was i too forward did i jump into
it real fast hey where are you from
that's what that felt like hey lol so
where you guys from no one cares where
we're from no one cares where we're from
no one's gonna remember oh matt is from
serbia i instantly
trust him with my life cool i'm from l.a
oh someone else is from l.a
damn it i gotta think of a neighborhood
oh no
y'all watch
real friends
yep uh first
uh one and a half season what is real
bros oh no i'm a fake man time to do the
podcast okay okay real bros was so
funny
i've put out a few questions
but i haven't got a response back yet
did anyone else have tmgs or top
podcasts for spotify
yeah i did lol oh my god they all had
the podcast i'm just gonna lie i'm gonna
lie i'm so nervous like i don't speak
i'm not speaking anything trillionaire
mindset uh only the first episode
see that that is a good question because
trillionaire mindset that is like
something that he produced but not a lot
of people know about it
honestly i think a slept on vid of his
is the that's cringe
valentine's edition
okay josh has been super quiet maybe
it's josh i don't know i literally have
no idea who the fake fan is at this
point it literally could be anyone it
could be me
was that was that a bad thing to say is
that too obvious
okay matt said fantastic fit
i think i'm fitting in right now
maybe i just don't say anything i think
i think i think i've i've said my piece
[Music]
i wasn't too aggressive i blended in
just fine i was a little bit boring so
it's between ashley and josh but i'm
going to wait on ashley and i'm going to
go with josh i'm going to say a mirror
but i'm like
not really suspicious like hardcore of
anyone right now um probably going to
vote out actually i'm going to vote for
matt on this round i think i'm going to
vote for joe
actually no i should i shouldn't vote
for joe i'ma vote for mckim i'm gonna
vote for josh though his bitmoji isn't
ironic enough i don't think i'm gonna
get voted off this round honestly i
think joe is i'm voting for joe joe's
acting real weird okay later joe
the person eliminated this round is
don't say josh
josh
how i was totally normal
why
was saying that season two was worth it
was that not
normal or was it the valentine's cringe
comment
maybe i just should have said nothing
maybe i didn't say enough maybe i wasn't
fast enough i don't know i played the
game the way i came to play and i'll
stand by that i'm proud of my
performance
i wanted to win
[Music]
okay so now i like this better just
observing although they're all fans now
so i might just go rogue and just be
like
what's going on with joe why is it being
so weird
any mr struggles in chat only i feel
like my favorite kodiko joke is mr
struggle guy number three that you
definitely shouldn't decor or marry is
mr struggle
this is not about goddamn struggles yeah
i've been mr struggle before do you guys
consider yourselves
godlike would you describe yourself as a
godly man yeah i'm constantly the top of
the leaderboard any video game
always i'm constantly
top of the leaderboard any reference
understanders
okay all these i guess as well does he
have any traditions
oh my god they asked about age they
asked about age this is the test
cody is around 30 85 not funny date of
birth a very long time ago
you guys
see the new
tattoo
he got
his new tattoo i don't follow him on
instagram yo did you guys see the new
tattoo he got
which one are you talking about no what
was it
okay so joe's calling people out he's
saying did you see the new tattoo and
then matt said no what was it and he
said wow dude wow
so are you a fan or what's good bro hey
joe what is this new tattoo
his new tattoo he just got it right the
suss
[Music]
he just called me for not knowing about
his new tattoo who knows about his new
tattoo everyone's freaking out about the
new tattoo
yeah he tattooed a smiley face in his
leg while he was drunk
yeah i did unfortunately no it's
actually sick though
um i was going to show you but it's
probably not appropriate for a jubilee
video hey here's my upper thigh how
would i know about his new tattoo also
they said that apparently the new tattoo
was actually in the newest episode of
the podcast super easy for a fake cody
cove fan to just watch the most recent
episodes i'm vodyaacho fiona is going to
be my vote it's us that joe was saying
someone says because we were all just
chilling but you know what amir again he
was more passive than active yeah i
think i'm gonna go from here i mean amir
could also just be like a noel stand i'm
gonna place my vote for joe
who do i think is getting voted out this
round may i don't know i'll just take a
guess amir and then if he gets voted out
i can be like oh i did something right
today
and the person eliminated this round in
round two
is
gonna be a mirror it's gonna be me
wait i got it right
i did it i did something good today
let's go
you will all have two minutes to think
of and caption the picture that is going
to be posted in the group chat
[Music]
i'm laughing that everyone is
downloading this picture their hard
drive right now
how do you even caption this what am i
supposed to do because everyone is going
to be like when the app is frictionless
because we're all tired of that
that's frictionless see what you got joe
what does that say
my face when kodiko makes another
useless podcast
hey bro this is cody and [ __ ] you see
what you got fiona
just drank some powder okay yeah
camus powder oh dude you're drinking
powder
good meme solid meme i don't even know
how i'm about to sing
let's see matt let's see
[Music]
[Laughter]
this isn't funny
that's pretty funny i mean i don't even
really get it but it's just funny
it's kind of it's kind of funny
when you're sponsored by love islands
you don't have to pay for the next
episode
i like this one because love island was
how i found it noel and cody
get it i don't get it i don't get it
sorry mckim i need more love island
episodes
ashley
when chili decides not to bark while
you're vlogging yeah okay i like that
one that wasn't that one's kind of funny
right chili
i know
memes are hard
that's what we've learned i can't do
them either
i feel like i'm being a dick i
will be voting for joe one plus one is
no longer equaling two i feel like i'm
just tunnel visioning on joe and joe
probably is just like a normal cody
co-fan
powder a good one but also could be a
recent watch i am suspicious of matt he
just his caption was just noah miller i
think that's a really funny meme
but it doesn't tell me that he knows
cody at all
we have a tie
the tie is between joe
and matt
of course of course it's
between i need to be specific i need to
be very specific
[Music]
[Applause]
uh when you're a collegiate athlete
when you have a
2.5 gpa my face when i'm not only a
dookie but also taking a dookie see if i
can recreate that smile
me after meditating and eating walnut
salad
[Music]
i'm gonna give that one in that you know
does anyone understand my deep cut i
feel like i'm being a hater all right
i'm so done with this walnut salad
you're diving in her dms i'm diving in
her
no it's not sonic
there's a joke by the way the the word
that you can't read there it probably
says pool right i'm diving in her pool
right
that probably says pool that's what he
meant right pool i know it's not oh it's
that has nothing to do with cody koh my
friends
1 000
voting for joe i will
vote for matt once more joe's was
definitely a deep cut and if we're just
looking for
the non-cody fan then i'm gonna go with
the deep cut and the person eliminated
this round is
max
so then are you saying the funnier meme
would be the fake fan because the real
fan
is this an insult to me somehow round
three just
spiraled down so quickly
if everyone feels confident that you
already voted out the mall you can end
the game now but if the majority has
doubt the game will continue uh ashley
fiona me
[Applause]
we're good i don't know about joe okay i
still think it's joe though we can
continue i think it's matt but i'm so
tall okay
it's over
it's over time to reveal myself
if the color that shows up is green you
all win if it's red the fake fan is
still in the game and you all lost
dude in
three please be red and please beat joe
please be ready
please be red please be
joe let's go i knew it i know
i knew it
i'm so smart i knew it was bad joe had
me bamboozled dude how is not joe yes
the game is over and the kodiko fans
have won
please
turn on your zoom cameras in three
two
one
[Music]
hey everybody
are you saying hi are you staying in the
mall
hey
oh my god
how did you guys vote me out first how
why
your vibe was off that's why we were
voting you out i had so i was like super
low-key about it i was like yeah oh but
that's cringe valentine's pretty funny
huh
and then you guys were like josh
josh cody thank you for being you
i know you hate compliments so yeah
honestly you're super funny you've
brought me closer to some of my best
friends so just thanks for being you and
thanks for all your content hell yeah
thank you
hey nice to meet you
all i appreciate it it was this was fun
oh man it is
it is such a dream to actually meet him
and talk and that was crazy he's helped
me through so many times like his videos
so it means a lot to like you know have
this experience it's really like i'm
proud to be a kodiko fan
you won oh my god so cool you guys won
thanks for watching odd one out
subscribe to me
codyco
um and subscribe to jubilee of course
and thank you jubilee for having me i
appreciate it
bye